cockpit opening and closing whenever
that thing opens it should make kind of
a goofy like like it's all really cool
and whenever he shows up there's kind of
that sound voice cuz I'm over the top
yeah that lets you know and it's kind of
funny cuz Olivier's a little he's a
little chagrined by it cuz yeah
obviously like it's like what something
cool yeah uh meetings great day whoa
what are we going to fix this guy huh
it's the rare Covarrubias in his natural
habitat oh hi we are in charge of
creating all of these sound design
elements for the creature the little guy
is ambassador's log from the planetoid
system whatever they are on a diplomatic
mission and he's his you know kind of
bodyguard right-hand man but he's really
there for the swag and the cool t-shirts
the implementation of it being inside
something that is an interactive
experience for people it's way different
from a movie the sounds have to work on
their own without really any input from
us after they're done great it's got
great low-end it's not going to be
distracting which is nice but it's there
it's really cool cool this is brandy and
we get more bass out of that
dehumanize err is a real-time voice
effector it does pitch shifting granular
synthesis pretty much anything you could
do to a voice to make some kind of
creature sound or otherworldly vocal
effect Tom has always been very adamant
about getting actors to come in and have
their performance become part of the
creature who did vote due to that even
if it's just you know efforts and things
like that and then manipulating them and
it just takes everything to a whole
different level in 3 & 4 gate 3 here's a
man range for speech however the
feedbags make you wanna talk here I also
feel like I'm having is soon and it
seems like every time you're working
with these voices if you have to going
back and forth you're creating new bits
and new things and that's really what's
going to carry it is going to be the
performance you just want you don't want
the effects to get into the way here's
the deal I push them out of the way you
apologize we'll get into that Convention
Center quickly that way I think that we
should take a more formal path if we're
going to be talking to the high Lord
ceptin pardon me probably out of God
excuse me don't worry about him he's
fine I can't wait to see like how kids
react to it oh my god don't you're gonna
love it just for the spectacle yeah but
it's it's different seeing a kid
actually believe what they're seeing is
real kids it's like instantly they are
asking questions they're you know
they're involved with with this thing
that you've created our pure imagination
Baskins on my planet it's five grams of
nitrogen okay so we have our two selects
for disa and high that is very lightly
alright it's fun
check out the Wired channel the scene
calm for the entire giant creature
series